loin des images habituelles c'est sans
doute une autre Jackie Kennedy que vous
venez de découvrir avec ce documentaire
réalisé par Maude Guillaumin comme
l'antiségrégationniste qu'elle était à
une époque où les Afro-Américains se
battait pour la pleine reconnaissance de
leurs droit l'occasion pour nous de
revenir sur la trajectoire de cette
icône des années 60 veuve à l'âge de 34
ans après avoir vécu à ses côtés
l'assassinat de son mari le président
John filgerald Kennedy c'est ce que nous
allons faire maintenant avec nos invités
présents aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de
débadoc mode Guillaumin est avec nous
bienvenue c'est donc vous qui avez
réalisé le film que nous venons de voir
vous êtes journaliste autrice et
documentariste vous avez par ailleurs
consacré l'un de vos ouvrages à Jackie
Kennedy intitulé Jackie une femme
d'influence publié aux éditions du
moment c'est un ouvrage qui a été publié
avant
la réalisation de ce documentaire on va
y revenir bien sûr dans un instant avec
hélenne arter bienvenue Hélen arter vous
êtes historienne professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université parien
Panthéon Sorbonne et directrice du
Centre de Recherche d'histoire
nord-américaine et du centre de
recherche d'études canadiennes et votre
dernier ouvrage ça tombe bien s'intitule
Jackie Kennedy un destin américain
publié aux éditions calye et puis en
préparation hein de votre côté bientôt
tout bientôt une biographie de and on a
hâte Dominique Simonet enfin est avec
nous bienvenue à vous vous êtes
journaliste écrivain et essayiste auteur
entre autres de first ladies à la
conquête de la Maison Blanche coécrit
avec la polyitologue nicole Bacharan est
disponible chez tampus ma Guillaumin des
films des livres sur Jackie Kennedy il y
en a eu beaucoup c'est peu de le dire on
y reviendra peut-être dans un instant
c'est une véritable star des années 60
elle et son mari
son premier mari JFK
euh pourquoi avoir choisi cet angle
particulier que vous nous avez présenté
dans ce documentairire alors au début
des années 2000 sa fille Caroline
Kennedy a accepté de publié des audios
8h d'interview qui étit normalement
souscellé jusqu'en 2067 demande de
Jackie Kennedy euh ces interviews
c'était ont été enregistrés en mars 64 à
après l'assassinat de son mari et elle y
parle vraiment politique c'est-à-dire
que elle donne son avis sur des points
importants
et j'ai fait donc tout un livre sur son
influence politique qu'on ne connaissait
pas du tout et là on se rend compte que
elle a été très importante que même son
mari lui a donné de l'importance puisque
par exemple il l'a envoyé au Pakistan et
en Inde alors qu'on est en pleine guerre
froide que ces deux pays cherchaient
leur camp est-ce qu'ils allaient aller
vers l'URSS est-ce qu'il ils allaient
aller vers les États-Unis et il l'a
laissé partir toute seule en tant que
représentante des États-Unis et
d'ailleurs quand elle est revenue il lui
a donné les les honneurs que normalement
on accorde aux ambassadeurs avec tous
les militaires qui ont leurs Sabr tenu
en l'air sur le tarmac ce qui prouve
vraiment donc c'est donc après ces
fameuses 8h d'interview qui ont été
rendu publi en 2011 hein hein 8h
d'interview réalisé par un historien qui
s'appelait Arthur Schlessinger Arthur
schlessinger4 a interviewé en effet des
tas de membres de de de la composition
du gouvernement mais aussi des proches
de Kennedy et évidemment sa femme et
c'est là où vraiment j'été très étonnée
parce que elle parle beaucoup des droits
civiqus et elle raconte que en plus
d'avoir ouvert les portes de la Maison
Blanche pour la première fois à des
Afro-Américains mais qui ne soient pas
seulement des actrices mais également
des directeurs d'université des prix
Nobel qu'on ne connaissait absolument
pas c'était une grande nouveauté et
vraiment c'est là où où elle insiste
beaucoup parce qu'elle veut que ce rôle
soit reconnu qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé de ce ce documentaire cet angle he
choisi par la réalisatrice qui est avec
nous sur ce plateau elle a autant que
cela contribué à la lutte en faveur du
mouvement des des droits civies aux
États-Unis à l'époque ou moi je je
trouve le documentaire très intéressant
parce qui montre bien une phase qu'on
connaît mal je trouve aussi intéressant
le le fait que vous ayez rappelé le
contexte on est juste après la mort du
président avec deux acteurs fondamentaux
que sont à la fois Jackie Kennedy et
Arthur Schlesinger Arthur schessinger il
faut s'en souvenir a été un très proche
conseiller du président pendant toute sa
présidence et même dès la campagne
présidentiel et il va ensuite être le
gardien de la flamme de l'héritage
Kennedy alors je dirais peut-être plus
précisément le gardien de la flamme de
l'héritage de John Kennedy puisque
Arthur schessinger va écrire un livre
euh qui va être consacré aux 1000 jours
de de la présidence de Kennedy on
pourrait citer deux autres livres hein
de conseillers Salinger Sorensen et en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est quand
on lit ces trois livres jacie Kennedy
est quasi absente et donc on voit bien
comment l'histoire de la présidence qui
s'est construite qui est une histoire
très politique se fait autour du
président et ce documentaire à ce mérite
c'est de dire que Jackie Kennedy a aussi
fait des choses alors c'est pour ça que
je vous ai posé la question parce que
maîtresse de la maison blanche certes
hein first ladies maîtresse de la Maison
Blanche mais est-elle autant influencée
que ça son mari dans les domaines
évoqués dans ce documentaire notamment
concernant la lutte pour les droits
civique c'est une très bonne question
parce que en fait il y a toute la
question et Jackie Kennedy est
importante en la matière de la
communication de ce qu'on montre et de
la mise en scène et elle a joué un rôle
très certainement du l'ordre symbolique
et on sait combien le le symbolique est
important mais le symbolique ne s'est
pas forcément traduit par des politiques
et on le voit très bien sur les droits
civiques elle a fait des gestes qui sont
des gestes importants mais je pourrais
dire en ayant travaillé sur isener que
ces gestes il commence avec Eisen Herer
et il commence déjà même avec Harry
Truman qui invite une cantatrice noire
lors de sa prise de fonction donc elle
est dans ce dans cette prise de
conscience et dans cette compréhension
que le symbolique est extrêmement
important mais ça ne se traduit pas en
politique parce que notamment vous le
savez certainement le Parti démocrate
qui est le parti du président Kennedy
est divisé et quand dans ses rang
énormément de sudistes qui sont hostiles
à cette politique donc c'est vraiment
cette idée que les actes vont
certainement aider à mener des
politiques mais elle est un peu trop tôt
hein c'est-à-dire que c'est finalement
la présidence de Lidon Johnson qui va
faire que on va abolir toutes les
politiques ségrégationnistes qui ont été
mentionnées donc voilà moi je trouve
c'est très intéressant parce que ça
donne un éclairage et ça montre qu'il y
a un allant et une volonté chez cette
femme de faire bouger les lignes ça pose
une question je me la suisosé en
regardant votre votre film c'est la
réelle influence de Jackie Kennedy sur
John fgeral Kennedy euh notamment en
matière politique parce que ce sont les
sujets abordés dans votre film oui oui
on a on a cette image qui est une vraie
image d'une
personne représentative d'une certaine
beauté enfin elle était elle était
magnifique glamour la mode Jackie
Kennedy c'est une légende c'est une
c'est une icône c'est une esthétique
même de
de l'Amérique et c'est vrai que plus on
avance dans les dans l'étude et et plus
des documents sont révélés moi j'ai eu
la chance de rencontrer Arthur
schessinger qui avait une grande
admiration d'ailleurs pour pour pour
Jackie qui effectivement a était l'un
des gardiens du temple de la de la
maison Kennedy il est le seul en tout
cas à avoir obtenu 8h d'interview avec
Jackie Kennedy hein par que par la suite
on en reparlera peut-être après ça pas
été le cas hein les interviews plus
partie de sa vie il était très proche de
de John et euh McNamara d'ailleurs qui
était le le secrétaire à la Défense
disait Jackie c'est la femme la plus
sous-estimée des États-Unis elle elle a
une acuité politique exceptionnelle et
est-ce que nous sommes en mesure quand
même d'évaluer l'influence qu'elle avait
sur son sur son mari de président il y a
deux grands domaines il y a un domaine
de la culture parce que effectivement
elle a joué un rôle il y a pas le
ministre de la Culture aux États-Unis
donc elle a joué un rôle culturel
notamment d'ailleurs en s'inspirant
beaucoup de la France c'était Merot qui
était à l'époque ministre de la Culture
qu'elle a rencontré on en parlera
peut-être mais il y a il y a un fameux
voyage des des Kennedy à Paris avec 1961
voilà avec malerot très très présent euh
et puis l'autre domaine c'est vous
l'avez un peu évoqué c'est la la
politique étrangère c'est-à-dire elle
avait cette espèce de comment dire de
talent de de pouvoir parler avec des des
chefs d'État euh et de et même avec
krutchev d'ailleurs ou ou ou avec nerou
et de de d'adoucir un petit peu les les
rapports tendus qui pouvaient y avoir au
niveau du du Département d'État ou du
Pentagone ou ou directement de la Maison
Blanche donc elle a joué un rôle pas
directement mais
d'influence absolument évident et et
donc cette image de Jackie Kennedy
aujourd'hui c'est une femme magnifique
c'est une icône
euh mais c'est aussi une pour moi en
tout cas c'est aussi une femme politique
qui illustre d'une certaine manière une
une une une forme d'influence féminine
dont on aujourd'hui on on ne peut que
admirer et découvrir la la de plus en
plus de de détails euh je je rebondisais
juste sur malerot c'est elle qui a
décidé en fait lors de ce voyage on lui
a demandé en France qui est-ce que vous
aimeriez rencontrer elle a dit moi j'ai
lu tous les livrre de malerot je veux
absolument rencontrer malerot Maler
vient de perdre ses deux fils quelques
jours avant euh il va venir parce qu'
qui a envie de rencontrer Jackie Kennedy
il y a une vraie amitié intellectuelle
qui va se créer et c'est grâce à ça
qu'elle va faire venir la Joconde à aux
États-Unis c'est un vrai combat
politique parce qu'elle veut montrer que
les États-Unis sont aussi une terre de
culture même si c'est une terre avec une
histoire très récente elle veut que ça
devienne une terre de culture je
rebondis sur l'idée culturelle et et
c'est pour ça que cet échange qui est
vraiment très très important
politiquement parce que faire venir la
Joconde qui est vraiment un symbole
français par excellence il va falloir
que malero convainque difficilement le
général de Gaulle qui va avoir un
intérêt politique pour des raisons
dessai nucléaires donc voilà on part en
effet je je dis exactement ce que vous
disiez c'est à la base un petit truc
mais politiquement parlant ça peut être
utilisé pour un élément très important
et elle voilà son idée c'est vraiment de
de valoriser l'image des États-Unis et
aussi au niveau culturel pour donner de
la valeur sur tous les points aux
États-Unis oui et on est très clairement
dans un S power américain avec un
président et son équipe qui a compris
l'image le rôle que pouvait jouer Jackie
Kennedy je nuancerait quand même parce
que finalement une fois que le voyage
est fait une fois que la Joconde est
venue ça ne change strictement rien au
relation diplomatiqu entre la France et
les États-Unis avec les les conflits les
tensions sur la question du
nucléaire sur des questions plus
largement de guerre froide
d'indépendance nationale tout ça ne
change strictement rien et on pourrait
dire exactement la même chose sur
l'Amérique latine où il y a une Jacky
Mania finalement au Canada c'est pareil
les opinions publiques sont séduit par
Jacky parce qu'elle incarne par le fait
qu'elle soit capable de parler en
espagnol donc elle va parler au peuple
elle va parler au cœur des gens mais
finalement en terme politique
l'effet proche de zéro hein et donc ça
je pense que c'est quand même un petit
peu la limite de l'influence
c'est-à-dire que elle contribue à rendre
les États-Unis plus humain en terme
d'image mais fondamentalement les grands
équilibres n'en sont pas changés même si
le général de Gaul est séduit par la
femme c'est pas pour autant que voilà
les force profond pour dire une relation
très particulière avec la
France c'est que elle a fait ses études
en France elle parle parfaitement le
français he avec un petit accent
américain craquant mais elle parle
parfaitement français délicieux ou
oui elle a étudié à Sorbonne elle a
étudi à l'École du Louvre euh à sciencep
aussi donc elle a à la fois une
littérature la politique étrangère donc
elle est elle est très imprégnée de de
d'éducation française effectivement
quand elle va se retrouver avec avec
John dans ce fameux voyage où John dit
euh euh au français je suis l'homme qui
a accompagné Jack Kennedy à Paris et
j'ai adoré avait-il dit à son arrivée à
Orly voilà donc d'une certaine manière
c'est le voyage de de Jackie et là elle
séduit elle séduit le le général de
Gaulle elle séduit Maler euh mais c'est
pour elle c'est effectivement c'est
c'est comment dire c'est une déclaration
d'amour
assez à son attachement à la à ses
origines françaises et à propos de de GA
elle avait elle avait l' dur vis-à-vis
de de degou pas seulement d'ailleurs à
travers cette très longue interview
qu'elle a accordé que nous avons évoqué
au début de cette émission de Gaulle
était mon héros quand j'ai épousé Jack
autrement dit John phigérald Kennedy
mais elle a rapidement changé d'avis
après avoir rencontré le le général lors
de cette fameuse visite de 61 où elle a
considéré qu'elle elle avait trouvé de
Gaul égocentrique et méchant hein alors
c'est pas par rapport à cette visite de
de 61 c'est après en fait donc elle
raconte ça en mars 64 après l'assassinat
de son mari et elle est extrêmement
déçue parce que de GA a annoncé que donc
il ne ratifierait pas les accords de non
prolifération nucléaire signé et lancé
par John fitgeral Kennedy mcman et
crutcheev et la France enfin Kennedy
espérait que la France évidemment
ratifie ce traité et de Gaulle refuse et
elle pour elle son travail là maintenant
c'est d'essayer de faire vivre le
travail les les 3 ans passés à la Maison
Blanche de son mari donc ça pour elle
c'est un un coup de poignière dans le
dos c'est une catastrophe parce qu'elle
est vraiment on se rend pas compte mais
elle est vraiment très politique et pour
elle comme pour les droits civiques
c'est vraiment c'est son mari qui a
lancé tout ça il faut faire vivre tout
ça et que ces choses-là ne passent pas
au nom de Lyon Johnson alors évidemment
on a d'ailleurs pas l'image de votre
film mais enfin l'image qu'on garde tous
de Jackie Kennedy c'est ce fameux 22
novembre 1963 Dallas Texas l'assassinat
de John fut Kennedy elle est à ses côté
dans la fameuse limousine noire h euh
ces images sont assez dramatiques le
choc est on ne peut plus violent on
l'imagine bien sûr elle va même jusqu'à
ramasser une partie des cerveaux de son
mari sur cette fameuse limousine euh et
là sa vie bascule sa vie bascule et
c'est c'est tout le drame de Jackie
Kennedy finalement oui et on voit bien
que finalement dans dans ces années-là
et l'interview de 64 est intéressante
elle est dans l'esprit des Américains
désormais complètement associée à la
présidence elle n'existe plus en tant
que elle-même elle est la veuve et cette
veuve donc elle va accepter ce rôle et
elle va le porter de de défense de du
bilan finalement et ce qu'elle veut
fondamentalement c'est qu'on se
souvienne de son mari pour son œuvre et
pas pour le fait qu'il ait été assassiné
et donc c'est tout son combat
c'est-à-dire pour elle Jack est grand
parce qu'il a accompli et non pas Jack
est grand parce que c'est un martyre et
en fait finalement c'est plutôt la
deuxème idée idée qui va prédominer et
on le voit bien à partir des années 1970
il y aura d'ailleurs une multiplication
de documentaires d'études
journalistiques d'études historiens qui
vont pointer les limites de la politique
Kennedy en particulier sur la question
de la relation avec l'Europe avec la
France parce que voilà les choses ne
vont pas dans le sens elle refusera de
s'exprimer ensuite he à propos du clan
Kennedy sa vie privée néanmoins
néanmoins la question vou vouser elle
était au premire log de de l'assassinat
de johngal Kennedy et pour cause est-ce
qu'elle a eu à témoigner devant la
commission waren devant la l'autre
commission d'enquête qui a qui a plus
tard en
1976 et entre 76 et 79 retravaillé he
sur ce cet assassinat de Jal Kennedy
est-ce qu'elle a eu à témoigner devant
ces ces deux commissions d'enquête
américaines elle a voulu témoigner mais
la chose qu'elle a fait après c'est
d'accepter les conclusions de la
commission he puisqu'on sait que dès
donc elle a voulu témoigner n'a pas
témoigné la la fameuse commission boen
par exemple en 64 ben c'est c'est de ça
don dont on parle en fait elle elle
témoigne et ensuite elle dit j'accepte
les conclusions et pourquoi elle le dit
mais parce que elle a peur que si on
creuse un peu plus hein et si notamment
on accepte les théories du complot bah
on va on va savoir que son mari et son
entourage a pu avoir des liens avec le
crime organisé on va interroger la
relation avec Cuba donc elle préfère
qu'on s'arrête sur cette idée du tueur
isolé plutôt que d'aller approfondir des
sujets qui remonteraiit et derrière il y
a aussi la famille Kennedy qui estime
que toute cette publicité ne peut être
que mauvaise et qu'il vaut mieux garder
l'image d'un homme martyre de la cause
plutôt que d'aller soutenir des enquêtes
plus approfondies même si eux la famille
n'est pas forcément totalement convaincu
par tout ça mais ils font de la
politique he il faut pas oublier que
Robert va être élu au Sénat des
États-Unis qu'il a ensuite des ambitions
présidentielles en 68 puis ensuite ses
aide donc ils n'ont pas intérêt à remuer
tout ce qui pourrait remonter à la
surface le le jour sur ce fameux moment
de l'assassinat sur ce
témoignage ce non témoignage peut-être
publique à travers ses interviews elle
elle n'a pas voulu en parler
publiquement qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
dire elle a eu un comportement quand
même
assez assez étonnant assez exemplaire ce
jour-là parce qu'elle a d'abord elle a
voulu garder vous savez ce fameux
tailleur rose qu'on voit sur toutes les
images elle a voulu le garder dans la
journée elle éta quand quand on le le
cercueil de de Kennedy a été apporté
dans le dans l'avion présidentiel pour
être amené à Washington elle a commencé
à se lever les mains et s'est dit non je
je garde je garde je garde la preuve de
ce qui s'est passé je veux que le monde
entier voit ce que l'on a fait à mon
mari et cette détermination là elle va
l'avoir elle l'a eu d'ailleurs pendant
son son séjour la M Maison Blanche elle
va le garder elle veut cultiver cette
image d'une présidence d'un couple uni
fort euh malgré les les les petits
secrets de John Kennedy qui
effectivement é trit avait d'abord avait
un mal de dos son autre secret c'était
qu' courrait les filles que Jackie était
pas très heureuse mais ça elle elle elle
va mettre tout son toute son énergie à à
construire une légende d'ailleurs elle
elle fait la comparaison avec la légende
du roi Arthur avec Camelo qui est une
comédie musicale qui au même moment est
très populaire aux États-Unis et elle va
organiser les funérailles d'une manière
absolument magistrale avec les chefs
d'État avec un cheval sans cavalier avec
le petit John John qui salue et elle va
recevoir aussi en privé pendant ce
moment-là des chap d'État don de Gaulle
en privé c'est d'ailleurs par ses
funérailles que que vous commencez votre
film exactement parce que je montre que
son acte politique il commence auos yeux
du monde avec ce cercueil porté par des
soldats noirs et des soldats blancs
c'est la prem première fois que les
soldats d'élite encore
d'élite laissent défiler des soldats
noirs et c'est sa décision toutes les
funérail c'est sa décision il faut quand
même bien voir que c'est là où le mythe
Kennedy elle veut vraiment le créer et
là on est dans de la manipulation
politique faut quand même appeler ça
comme ça quand on revient sur camelotte
hein donc cette comédie musicale en gros
elle dit dans l'interview qu'elle
qu'elle accorde qui elle va être publiée
à un autre journaliste elle va dire que
c'était un moment qu'il n'y aura plus
jamais de camelotte que ce moment avec
son mari et ses enfants c'était un
moment merveilleux de l'Amérique donc
vraiment elle est dans un espèce d'une
espèce de féerie politique où là on est
vraiment dans la la volonté politique de
marquer à jamais l'histoire et ce qui
est très impressionnant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les Américains font
encore référence à la période Kennedy en
parlant de camelotte donc quand même son
coup marketing moi m'a beaucoup
impressionné parce que au départ surtout
de une vision française j'ai trouvver ça
presque ridicule enfin est-ce qu'on
dirait de la période de Gaulle c'était
merveilleux c'était Merlin l'enchanteur
non vraiment enfin c'est pour nous
Français c'est hallucinant notreame de
Paris mais ça marche très très bien aux
États-Unis et et et donc elle veut créer
cette image parfaite je rebondis juste
sur un un autre élément ce petit John
John qui salue jamais voulait que ses
enfants soient photographiés l'image
qu'on connaît de de John John sous le
bureau de son son mari c'est c'est c'est
son père qui pendant qu'elle est pas là
fait venir les photographes elle a
toujours refusé qu'on les voit et là
elle les utilise parce qu'elle sait que
là la famille donc l'intime au moment de
ce ce cet enterrement politique l'intime
et politique qui vont être mêlés
ensemble ça restera jamais dans
l'histoire c'est le début de l'IRE de
l'image en fait elle a compris elle a
compris ce qui se passait avec la
télévision qui qui est qui est partout
dans tous les foyers d'ailleurs c'est
comme ça que que John Kennedy a gagné
les élections avec un face- à faceace à
avec Nixon où il il s'en est sorti
beaucoup plus charismatique elle elle
fabrique une image c'est quand même la
sans doute une des premières fois où on
on voit une une fabrication d'une d'une
d'une présidence et déjà elle pense à
l'histoire c'est c'est ça qui est
formidable elle elle elle elle elle elle
voit le comment euh la présidence
Kennedy va être perçu comme aujourd'hui
des des années des décennies après et et
elle organise ça jusqu'à prévoir les
délais des des Ben des des
enregistrements des des papiers de la
Maison Blanche et même le tailleur voilà
2067 c'est ça le tailleur est donc
souscellé pour pour voilà c'est il y a
une construction d'un mythe et d'une
légende avec une avec un talent
exceptionnel alors s'il y a pas matière
tout de même à déconstruire ce myth
Jackie Kennedy le mythe John Phil geral
Kennedy a été déconstruit hein vous
l'avez dit hein
addicte sexuellement addicte par les
drogues tout cela a été dit redit
aujourd'hui à propos de John fgal
Kennedy qu' a pas matière à déc
construire un tout petit peu le le myth
papier glacé qu'on a de Jackie
Kennedy notamment après la mort de John
feral Kennedy elle a été faite de quoi
la vie de Jackie après un mariage avec
onis un tableau de chasse assez
impressionnant he si on en croit les les
divers lecture que j'ai pu faire en
préparant cette
émission alors Robert Kennedy le frère
de de John fgeral Kennedy mais aussi
Marlon Brando William Holden Sinatra
Warren Betty et puis deux personnages
qui l'ont demandé en mariage semble-t-il
après la mort de de son mari d'une part
David orby Gor qui éit un diplomate
britanique qui avait beaucoup uvré du
côté de la maison blanche du temps de
JFK et John colle
Wek architecte avec qui à qui d'ailleurs
elle avait confié he le l'architecture
du Mémorial hein Kennedy qui se trouve
au cœur du du cimetière
d'Arlington de quoi a été faite la vie
de de Jackie Kennedy après euh au-delà
de ce tableau autrre chasse que je viens
de citer mais on n'est pas du tout dans
cette image de la Veuve Noire làin qu'on
qui qui débute ce documentaire pour la
suite de sa vie elle est intéressante
parce qu'on a parlé de fabrication et de
construction de l'image et ces années 61
63 sont des années de construction
d'image c'est une femme qui ne parle pas
elle donne très peu d'interview hein il
y a cette fameuse interview où elle fait
visiter la Maison Blanche après qu'elle
est restaurée où on l'entend un petit
peu parl elle est déjà un problème pour
les les services de presse de la Maison
Blanche parce que les service de presse
de la Maisonblanche aimerait qu'elle
parle et qu'elle qu'elle a un discours
de de soutien à la politique de son mari
qu'elle ait une action peut-être plus
politique parce que finalement elle est
dans le symbole mais les actions
politiques par exemple faire campagne
pendant l'élection de 62 il faut quand
même se rappeler que Dallas c'est parce
que son mari lui a un peu forcé la main
pour qu'elle aille faire campagne au
Texas qui risque de basculer chez les
républicain et donc en fait les années
post 63 sont dans cette logique de la
con ution de l'image et on peut dire
qu'entre 63 et 68 elle se cherche
beaucoup parce que elle est comme
prisonnière de cette image de veuve et
il y a un moment cette image lui pèse
donc elle veut retrouver sa VI par les
Paparadis oui elle est traquée par les
Paparadis ce qui est quand même nouveau
pour une pour une femme de président ou
une veuve de président elle est devenue
people finalement et donc le respect
qu'on doit n'existe plus avec toute une
série de photos qu'on critique beaucoup
parce que le corps est quand même un peu
dén puis ensuite très dénudée
complètement dénudée et donc elle est
dans cette période où elle se cherche
elle se réinvente elle est rattrapée par
la campagne de 68 où son beaufrère
Robert est candidat et on le sait est
assassiné au mois de juin Robert qui
était la M de de Jackie alors on a pas
de témoignage direct de l'un ou de
l'autre mais tout
laisseens ils étaient très proches et
donc en fait elle prend la porte de
sortie et de en en acceptant l'offre de
mariage aristotoncis et on voit bien que
bah désormais la politique le politique
tout ça est très secondaire mais mais il
faut aussi quand même rappeler que c'est
une femme qui n'aimait pas la politique
elle aimait peut-être les idées
politiques mais elle n aimait pas la
quotidienneté la matérialité du
politique et par exemple faire campagne
ça envie de réagir l'assassinat de de de
Bob Kennedy est un est un choc un choc8
hein Kennedy Robert
Kenedy elle dit je veux plus de ce pays
ils sont en train d'assassiner les
Kennedy
voilà elle ne veut plus de ce pays et
elle a un rejet de de l'Amérique et elle
part effectivement euh après elle
reviendra elle sera surtout elle se
marie ouais elle se marie avec con assis
après l'assassinat de de Robert Kennedy
il faut il faut quand même aussi
reconnaître cette violence qui qui qui a
jalonné l'histoire de Kennedy et
l'histoire de cette époque c'est pour
elle qui a vécu ça dans sa chair c'est
effectivement quelque chose de de de
terrible elle reviendra après quand même
elle va après la bitr sur la 5e Avenue
là à New yorkork elle travaillera à New
York comme éditrice euh mais elle elle a
été euh d'une certaine manière elle là
aussi elle incarne l'Amérique elle a été
euh marquée profondément par ses
événements historiques elle de manière
personnelle mais c'est c'est c'est en ça
qu'elle est aussi intéressante elle elle
elle oui elle représente elle elle elle
elle elle transcende une l'Amérique qui
a elle aussi a été absolument totalement
choquée par par les deux assassinats
celui de Jacques et celui de de de de
Bob quelques années plus tard je rajoute
un autre assassinat qu'il a beaucoup
marqué qu'on voit dans le film c'est
l'assassinat de Martin Luther King c'est
la première fois qu'elle refait une
apparition publique elle va à
l'enterrement alors qu'elle ne va aucun
événement politique donc ça c'est
vraiment là aussi pour marquer les
droits civiques égal Kennedy c'est
vraiment pour ça aussi qu'elle y va et
parce qu'elle est vraiment très très
choquée de elle a rencontré Martin
Luther King en même temps que Kennedy a
lui-même rencontré Martin Luther King
quand il est invité en secret à la
Maison Blanche et justement Kennedy
voulait absolument qu'elle soit là pour
fluidifier les choses je reviens juste
sur un élément important il est vrai que
après après la mort
d'onacis euh pant pendant le mariage
avec Onasis pense de naasiste 1975 elle
est complètement perdue dans l'argent
elle pense qu'à l'argent je pense que
vraiment elle se perdait complètement
voilà elle va revenir aux États-Unis et
là elle va quand même faire d'autres
actes politiques qui sont importants
qu'elle connaît bien c'est-à-dire
défendre l'histoire le patrimoine
américain elle va se battre elle va même
aller à Washington de New York à
Washington pour défendre le fait que la
gare centrale Grand Central ne soit pas
démolie et plusieurs autres bâtiments
notamment tout autour de Washington
quand on on va à la Maison Blanche tout
autour il y a un quartier du 19e siècle
qui devait être complètement rasé et ça
devait être des grandes tours là aussi
elle va se battre pour ça elle va
vraiment avoir un rôle là-dessus vous
avez parlé du musée du Mémorial Kennedy
qu'elle a fait ériger elle s'est
énormément batue pour ça voilà c'est ces
c'est ces points-là et après sa carrière
d'éditrice elle va avoir une influence
euh
importante notamment parce que elle
estime qu'il faut faire vivre
l'architecture la culture voilà c'est
ces points-là où elle va faire de la
politique plus jamais de la vraie
politique américaine ça c'est c'est sûr
elle ne fera que deux interviews
semble-t-il officielle très courte en
après la la fameuse interview qu'elle
aura euh réalisé en 74 qu'on a
évoqué très peu présente sur de ce point
de vue-là sur dans l'espace public ah
oui oui oui des anecdote il y a tout les
photos à ce moment-là sont volés sont
des
PAP à la Maison Blanche comme elle a
fait ce cet énorme travail de de
conservation de patrimonialisation on
décide de baptiser le le jardin de la
Maison Blanche jacie Kennedy elle n'est
elle est invitée elle ne vient pas donc
elle a vraiment décidé de se retirer
mais moi je dirais une question qu'on a'
pas évoqué c'est que elle est à l'image
de l'évolution de la place des femmes
dans la société américaine c'est-à-dire
qu'elle née en 29 quand une femme de la
de la très- bonne société en attend
d'elle qu'elle soit décorative et
qu'elle aide la carrière de son mari et
c'est ce qu'elle fait et d'ailleurs on
s'en souvient avec Fast d'ailleurs car
elle est très dépensière aussi Jackie
Kennedy vous l'avez évoqué à mimoouou
mais c'est son milieu elle a toujours
baigné dans beaucoup d'argent enfin
gagner euh gagner de l'argent pour vivre
c'est un concept qu'elle ne maîtrise pas
ouais et on se rappelle certainement on
l'a dit elle a fait des études à la
Sorbonne mais elle a été aussi
photojournaliste donc c'est une femme
qui est intelligente mais qui s'arrête
qui met sa vie professionnelle entre
parenthèses quand elle devient une
épouse elle devient la femme de Jack
c'est tout elle n même pas Jacky et donc
quand elle est veuve pour la seconde
fois elle a dépassé la cinquantaine ses
enfants on grandi elle se demande ce
qu'elle va faire et elle suit
l'évolution de ces femmes américaines
alors elle est pas féministe mais mais
elle a un job elle est indépendante
financièrement elle fait ce qu'elle veut
de sa vie elle vit avec un homme sans
être marié elle se lance dans l'édition
elle fait ce qui lui plaît d'une
certaine manière et la seule interview
qu'elle donne finalement c'est à une
féministe américaine extrêmement connue
et elle pose un prérequis je ne veux pas
qu'on m'interroge sur mes deux maris je
ne parlerai que de sujet qui
m'intéressent et de ma vie d'aujourd'hui
il nous reste une minute quelle image on
a encore les Américains de Jackie
Kennedy c'est toujours une icône ou pas
ou voilà le temps a passé oui oui oui
Jackie Kennedy cétait oui oui c'est que
c'est évidemment c'est une figure c'est
une figure euh de l'histoire une figure
bon c'était aussi la présidence Kennedy
a été très très courte elle s'est
terminée d'une manière dramatique ça a
été une présidence quand même euh
beaucoup de choses se sont passées la
conquête lunaire le le a le le les
droits civiques enfin en tout cas le le
début de euh des droits civics il y a eu
beaucoup de choses qui qui restent
encore comme l'idée d'une Amérique jeune
dynamique qui qu'elle est de qu'elle est
de l'Alan et effectivement Jacky
représente à la foois cette Amérique là
cette Amérique des des des années 60 qui
veut qui veut donner de l'élan la femme
des des années 60 aussi qui commence à à
revendiquer un certain nombre de de
droits et aussi peut-être elle je pense
qu'elle a elle symbolise aussi une forme
de oui je disais tout à l'heure une
forme d'esthétique euh de qui qui reste
aujourd'hui trèss très très moderne je
dirais ça reste une femme moderne ça
sera le mot de la fin un grand merci
vraiment à tous les trois pour avoir
participé à ce débat dooc spécialement à
vous euh merci pour ce documentaire euh
merci à vous qui a alimenté cette
émission desbatoc aujourd'hui
documentaire bien sûr consacré à Jackie
Kennedy dont on a longuement parlé
ensemble sur ce plateau vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtagdbatdoc et je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un tout prochain débat
doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]